premiere bei den grünen annalena
baerbock ist kanzlerkandidat in der
partei mit der 40 jährigen an der spitze
wollen die grünen in die bundestagswahl
ziehen fällt heute abend die
entscheidung im machtkampf der union der
cdu bundesvorstand berät im moment über
die frage laschet oder söder streit um
eine neue fußball liga nach dem 12
europäische spitzenklubs die super
league gründen reagiert die uefa mit
scharfen drohung
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers ich willkommen in
einer neuen nachrichten woche und guten
abend hinein
kristin otto ist hier und sie hat
einiges vom sport mehr als wurde dem
fußball guten abend gleich zwei mal
steht die k-frage heute im mittelpunkt
einmal ist sie gegenstand eines
zunehmend fassungslos beobachteten
machtpokers bei cdu und csu
dazu gleich mehr die grünen klären das
heute geräuschlos und einvernehmlich
ihre erste kanzlerkandidaten in der
geschichte heißt annalena baerbock
sie ist von den beiden vorsitzenden der
grünen als siegerin hervorgegangen
ihr kollege robert habeck präsentierte
das heute so und wo es heute der moment
zu sagen dass die erste grüne
kanzlerkandidatin annalena baerbock sein
wird erstmals in ihrer über 40-jährigen
geschichte rechnen sich die grünen
chancen aus ins kanzleramt einzuziehen
viel optimismus gepaart mit
machtanspruch mehr von las bohnsack sie
hat also den vortritt erhalten annalena
baerbock hat sich in einem unaufgeregten
verfahren durchgesetzt sie ist die erste
kanzlerkandidatin der grünen dass die 40
jährige bislang über keinerlei
regierungserfahrung verfügt für sie kein
manko ja ich war noch nie kanzlerin auch
noch nie ministerin
ich trete an für erneuerung für den
status quo stehen anderem berbalk wirbt
für sich und für einen politischen
aufbruch deutschland brauche einen
neuanfang ich möchte anbieten eine
politik die vorausschau auf die was
neues wagt die den menschen zuhört und
ihn aber auch wirklich was zutraut auch
wenn sich die parteien ihrer thematik
mittlerweile breit aufgestellt hat so
will berbalk auch und gerade mit grüner
klimapolitik punkten
klimaschutz ist die aufgabe unserer zeit
die aufgabe meiner generation und
entsprechend will ich dass die politik
einer neuen bundesregierung klimaschutz
für alle bereiche zum maßstab macht und
robert habeck als verlierer sieht sich
der unterlegene jedenfalls nicht ich
selbst werde in den nächsten phasen noch
stärker als zuvor
meine regierungserfahrung und die
erfahrung von mehrfach erfolgreich
abgeschlossenen koalition zur handlung
nutzen um die partei auf die
regierungsübernahme vorzubereiten
eine klare aufgabenteilung also ob die
funktioniert wird sich noch zeigen
müssen
eins ist jedenfalls spätestens seit
heute klar die grünen setzen im
wahlkampf nicht auf platz sondern auf
sieg
seit drei jahren führt annalena baerbock
die grünen jetzt wird sie noch stärker
im mittelpunkt der aufmerksamkeit stehen
als erste kanzlerkandidaten der grünen
und einzige kanzlerkandidatin bei dieser
wahl ein porträt von markus dütschler
annalena baerbock 40 jahre alt juristin
geboren und aufgewachsen im großraum
hannover
doch die politische karriere startete in
ihrer neuen heimat in brandenburg 2005
tritt sie bei den grünen ein wird 2009
landesvorsitzende und sitzt seit 2013 im
bundestag 2018 damals noch relativ
unbekannte kämpferische sprung an die
spitze der partei mit ko parteichef
hubert haben wir heute nicht nur die
frau an robert seite sollen dann die
neue bundesvorsitzende von bündnis 90
die grünen ein
sie gilt in der partei als realo als
expertin in der klima und der
europapolitik mit blick auf weitere
aufgaben sagte sie in einem interview
drei jahre als parteichefin abgeordnete
und mutter kleiner kinder stellen
ziemlich jetzt hat annalena baerbock ihr
nächstes ziel vor augen das kanzleramt
und dann bringen wir schon controller
banerjee mit in die sendung in berlin
guten namen schock und alaa welche
chancen hat annalena baerbock denn
tatsächlich kanzlerin zu werden also in
aktuellen umfragen reicht es für die
grünen momentan nur zum juniorpartner in
einer schwarz-grünen koalition aber zum
ersten mal in der geschichte der partei
fehlen nur wenige prozentpunkte dann
könnte sich das drehen zum beispiel wenn
sie stärkste partei in einer dreier
konstellation werden und deswegen ist es
jetzt umso spannender zu sehen wie sich
annalena baerbock beweist ob sie bei
einer breiten wählerschaft punkten kann
denn als die junge frau hat sie
wahrscheinlich pluspunkt über denjenigen
die jetzt auch personell einen
kompletten wechsel im politikstil haben
wollen aber sie muss eben auch menschen
überzeugen die sich eine solide
kanzlerin wünschen und die sich
vielleicht fragen kann eine 40 jährige
ohne jegliche regierungserfahrung diese
rolle tatsächlich seriös ausfüllen
vielleicht auch deshalb setzten die
grünen heute weiter darauf dass sie im
wahlkampf teamarbeit machen sagen wir
haben ein spitzenduo und eine
kanzlerkandidatin und außerdem ganz viel
regierung regierungserfahrung aus elf
bundesländern ob sich das am ende so
auszahlt das werden die nächsten monate
im wahlkampf zeigen
ich mag unter vielen dank für
diese analyse kanzlerkandidatin bei den
grünen deutlich problematischer läuft
das ganze bei cdu und csu von union
keine spur die beiden kandidaten armin
laschet und markus söder haben bereits
mehrere selbst gesetzte fristen auch
selbst gerissen
jetzt scheint aber einiges an bewegung
da reinzukommen nach acht tagen
machtkampf überlässt die csu die frage
nun der schwesterpartei cdu
söder hat heute mittag angekündigt er
werde sich der entscheidung etwa des cdu
bundesvorstands beugen und der takt
jetzt im moment christiane hübscher nach
einer woche eskalation einen
überraschend zurückhaltender auftritt
von markus söder in münchen
der csu-chef erneuert seinen
machtanspruch legt aber dann sein
schicksal scheinbar demütig wieder in
die hände der großen schwester ich
persönlich bin bereit verantwortung zu
übernehmen und das gilt wenn eine breite
mehrheit der cdu dies will und trägt wir
respektieren jede entscheidung meine
bereitschaft war und ist immer ein
angebot aber die entscheidung darüber ob
dieses angebot angenommen werden kann
oder nicht ist kann nur die cdu
letztlich treffen sie ist die größere
schwester es wird sie auch immer bleiben
bereitet hier einer seinen rückzug vor
oder ist es doch nur noch mehr druck für
armin laschet den cdu-parteichef dem in
den letzten tagen immer mehr
unterstützung wegbricht er will die
entscheidung nun offenbar schnell
herbeizwingen ich habe für heute 18 uhr
den bundesvorstand eingeladen im lichte
der gespräche der letzten tage die
situation zu beraten und ich werde dem
bundesvorstand einen vorschlag machen
wie wir jetzt sehr schnell die nicht
geklärte frage zwischen cdu und csu
auflösen weil sich zwei männer eine
woche lang nicht einigen konnten steht
der cdu bundesvorstand vor einem dilemma
dem eigenen vorsitzenden in den rücken
fallen oder ihn gegen den willen großer
teile der basis zum kanzlerkandidaten
machen
nach berlin zu theo koll theus irgendwie
absehbar für wen das jetzt aus geht
heute abend nun strategisch ist die lage
ziemlich kompliziert ist eine fast
dialektische zwickmühle denn markus
söder hat seine kandidatur aufrecht
erhalten und gleichzeitig die
entscheidung in die hand des
cdu-bundesvorstands gelegt das könnte
man so verstehen dass wieder bereit ist
einzuknicken daran glaubt hier aber
niemand es könnte auch heißen dass es
gestern nacht eine absprache zu seinen
gunsten gegeben hat dass laschet als
kandidaten vorschlägt und damit das
gesicht war der hätte ja zugreifen
können aber mit blick auf die umfragen
beuge er sich der personalie söder zum
wohle des wahlerfolgs für ein solches
szenario hat wolfgang schäuble
vorsichtshalber schon mal unter druck
gesetzt wenn ihr die kanzlerkandidatur
abgebe dann verlöre er auch den
cdu-vorsitz flaschen hat zu beginn hier
klar gesagt er sei zur kandidatur bereit
und der tag der entscheidung sei
gekommen am mittag hatte er für die
sitzung einen vorschlag angekündigt wie
die nicht geklärte frage in dieser woche
sehr schnell aufgelöst werden könne das
spricht eigentlich gegen eine abstimmung
des bundesvorstands über ihn und über
die kandidatenfrage am heutigen abend es
könnte aber heißen dass es dass er
andere entscheidungsprozesse im sinn hat
und da hat es ja und vorschlägen nicht
gemangelt also fortsetzung folgt viele
fragen noch theo herzlichen dank nach
berlin für den moment und mehr zur
k-frage in der union und bei den grünen
sehen sie gleich nach uns in einem zdf
spezial und über die kanzlerkandidatin
der grünen gibt es in der zdf- heute-
app mehr informationen
ein ausführliches porträt von annalena
baerbock
so jetzt unser nächstes thema heute
abend corona da hat die eu ihre option
auf weitere 100 millionen impfstoff
dosen von bayern weitergezogen
damit erhalten die mitgliedstaaten laut
bayern tag dieses jahr insgesamt 600
millionen dosen
das decke zwei drittel der eu
bevölkerung ab die aktuellen deutschen
kroner zahlen sehen so aus das robert
koch institut meldet 11 1437
neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden das
sind 1808 weniger als vergangenen montag
die bundesweite sieben tage inzidenz
liegt bei 165,3 nach einem wochenende
sind die zahlen wegen fehlender
meldungen nach wie vor mit vorsicht zu
behandeln um von den hohen
infektionszahlen herunter zu kommen will
die regierung ja die sogenannte bundes
notbremse weil die kritik vor allem aus
der opposition aber deutlich war haben
die koalitionsfraktionen ihren entwurf
geändert
darin stehen jetzt weniger scharfe
ausgangssperren die schulen sollen
dagegen schon früher schließen jetzt ab
einer inzidenz von 165 über morgen
entscheidet der bundestag einen tag
später berät der bundesrat christoph
festival
es ist kompliziert mit der nächtlichen
ausgangssperre
ohne bindende vorgaben aus berlin gilt
sie mal hier mal dort mancherorts auch
schon wieder nicht mehr wegen der
unklaren rechtslage stuttgart setzt seit
vorgestern auf die sperre
was ich aber erst langsam rumspricht
und sie schafft
ab montag 9
wie schon im gange 1 20 uhr jetzt bitte
auf direktem weg in das alte problem mit
den corona maßnahmen jeder region jedes
land schützt sich nach eigenem ermessen
gegen das virus besonders mecklenburg
vorpommern geht auf nummer sicher
ab heute mit ausgangssperre in rostock
termin shoppen geht auch nicht mehr zum
dritten mal müssen die händler dort
dicht machen es geht nicht mehr lange so
weiter also jetzt allmählich müsste mal
entweder irgendwie was passieren ich
sage einfach mal entweder ein hilfspaket
vom staat oder wir bekommen wieder einen
ordentlichen kundenstrom rhein mit der
bundesweiten notbremse könnten die
geschäfte vielleicht gleich wieder
öffnen die nämlich wird wohl weniger
streng als geplant wir sind uns in der
koalition nach hartem ringen am
wochenende auch einig geworden dass wir
letztlich zu veränderungen hier kommen
wollen
statt um 9 soll die nächtliche
ausgangssperre jetzt doch erst um zehn
uhr abends beginnen und bis mitternacht
ausnahmen erlauben nämlich joggen und
spazierengehen alleine wohlgemerkt das
einkaufen mit termin im einzelhandel
wird wohl nicht schon ab incidents 100
sondern erst ab 150 verboten schulen
dagegen würden schon ab 165 er institut
schließen müssen
reicht das um die intensivstation zu
entlasten unklar aber es wäre immerhin
eine regel für das ganze land in der
pandemie ist china der große lichtblick
für die deutschen autobauer
denn der volkswagen konzern bmw und
daimler verkaufen dort inzwischen jedes
dritte ihrer autos und es ist noch luft
nach oben vor allem bei den in china
sehr beliebten e autos vw etwa hofft
dort noch in diesem jahr mehr als
100.000 e fahrzeuge absetzen zu können
über die chancen der aktuellen deutschen
modelle in fernen horst stefanie
schöneborn
die automesse in shanghai mit echtem
publikum fühlt sich an wie aus einer
anderen zeit
es ist international die grösste messe
china kommt wirtschaftlich im vergleich
zum rest der welt besser durch die
pandemie die deutsche automobilindustrie
hängt ab vom wachstum des landes bmw
mercedes verkaufen rund 35 prozent ihrer
autos nach china volkswagen sogar 40
prozent und der konzern will 15
milliarden euro in elektromobilität
investieren
wir planen ja allein in china bis ende
23 8 verschiedene fahrzeuge auf den auf
die plattform unter der marke volkswagen
zu setzen chinesische marken setzen voll
auf elektromobilität vernetzung und
künstliche intelligenz der chinesische
kunde will immer und überall online sein
so beschreibt es der influenza und
videoblogger boccia das auto ein mobiler
freund mit dem man reden kann
alle mögen deutsche autos aber besonders
bei den neuen technologien der
vernetzung künstlicher intelligenz
hinken deutsche unternehmen wie bmw
mercedes audi vw hinterher
der staat steckt viel geld in die
produktion chinesischer elektroautos und
lockt den käufer mit günstigen
förderpakete bisher profitieren davon
vor allem chinesische firmen
unser nächstes thema nach russland im
fall navalny steigt der druck auf den
kreml aus den usa und auch von der
europäischen union
der eu außenbeauftragte chaussee pour l
machte die russischen behörden
verantwortlich für einiges
gesundheitszustand und der sei
besorgniserregend
alexej nawalny ist jetzt in ein
gefängniskrankenhaus verlegt worden für
begann berichtet misshandlung wollte das
krankenhaus der strafkolonie 3 ist
berüchtigt hierher wurde alexej nawalny
heute verlegt neue sorgen also für seine
ärzte dieser tagen um das leben des
kreml kritikers fürchten seine kalium
werte sind sehr hoch die kreatinin werte
steigen das deutet auf ein drohendes
nierenversagen hin dieser mensch muss
gerettet werden
ende märz begann alexei navalny einen
hungerstreik
rund 20 kilo habe er seit seiner
inhaftierung verloren wenn er rede lege
er den kopf vor erschöpfung immer wieder
auf die tischplatte berichtet navalny
frau nach einem besuch im gefängnis
sorge bei den eu-außenministern maas
nach dem treffen in brüssel
dem scheint ist ja ganz grundsätzlich
weiterhin sehr schlecht zu gehen dass
auch aufgrund einer haft situation in
der er überhaupt nicht sein dürfte wenn
russland sich an seine völkerrechtlichen
verpflichtungen aus der europäischen
menschenrechtskonvention hielt und ihn
endlich auch frei ließ navalny
mitstreiter finden drastische worte für
ihre einschätzung der lage
sie sehen gerade wie ein mensch getötet
wird
ganz egal wie sehr man sich davon
fernhalten wenn es ignorieren das thema
wechseln will
all das ändert nichts an der tatsache
dass alexej nawalny auf grausame art
getötet wird vor den augen aller
russlands gefängnisbehörde hingegen
nennt navalny ist gesundheitszustand
akzeptabel
es sei mit einer vitamin therapie
begonnen wurden
kapstadt gilt als eine der schönsten
städte der welt seit gestern brennt es
in südafrikas touristenmetropole und
zwar gewaltig das feuer am tafelberg ist
auf teile der universität über
bohnen mehrere historische gebäude
wurden zerstört tausende studenten
mussten ihre wohnungen verlassen
starke winde erschweren die
löscharbeiten die feuerwehr konnte nach
eigenen angaben die ausbreitung gegen
mittag aber zunächst stoppen
die nasa meldet bei ihrer mars-mission
eine echte premiere zum ersten mal
überhaupt ist ein hubschrauber auf einem
anderen planeten geflogen immerhin 30
sekunden lang und bis zu drei meter hoch
der mars roboter hatte den mini
helikopter namens ingenuity vor wenigen
tagen abgesetzt seine rotoren müssen
sich wegen der extrem dünnen mars
atmosphäre fünfmal so schnell drehen wie
auf der erde und dann heute mittag
gelingt es ingenuity fliegt und landet
es kann eine neue ära bedeuten für die
erforschung des mars sylvia bleßmann
berichtet die reise zum mars und die
landung kim jee zurücktrat hatte der
helikopter unbeschadet am bauch des
rovers passivieren es überstanden
auch beim absetzen keine probleme wie ss
helfer des rovers anfang april belegten
mit spannung wurde nun erwartet ob er
unter marktbedingungen auch genug
auftrieb entwickeln kann um abzuheben
die mars atmosphäre ist unheimlich dünn
die beträgt ungefähr ein prozent der
atmosphäre der erde und der mittlere
druck auf der oberfläche ist nur
ungefähr sechs media und dass es
ungefähr so als würde man versuchen
einen hubschrauber hier auf 30
kilometern höhe auf der erde frieden zu
lassen
die rotorblätter müssen beim us flügen
um ein vielfaches schneller kreisen als
die ersten daten vom höhenmesser die
erde erreichten großer jubel in
kalifornien dann ein erstes schatten
foto vom heli freude auch bei der
deutschen im team die mit der zoom
kamera am rover das ereignis
dokumentieren durfte
das ist natürlich ein historisches
ereignis was wir hier gerade erlebt
haben denn wir haben gerade den ersten
motorisierten flug auf einem anderen
planeten erlebt und haben gerade ein
erstes video gesehen auf dem man
wirklich gesehen hat wie der
hubschrauber auf die 2.500 von nuthe
beschleunigt die rotorblätter und dann
abhebt und dort schwebt und sich ein
stück weit herum dreht und dann langsam
wieder runter nur 30 sekunden dauerte
dieser drei meter hohe schwebeflug in
den nächsten tagen sollen weitere folgen
ingenuity die eiskalten mars nächte
weiterhin gut übersteht so jetzt einiges
los im fußball ist ihm wichtig viel
aufruhr mit massiver kritik reagieren
internationale fußball ligen und
verbände auf die pläne einiger
top-vereine eines super league zu
gründen auch der dfb und die dfl zeigen
sich zitat erschüttert die uefa erwägt
harte strafen bis hin zum ausschluss von
real madrid dem fc chelsea und
manchester city in der laufenden
champions league die großen sind dabei
lionel messi mit barcelona oder der fc
liverpool mit jürgen klopp letzte nacht
hatten zwölf top klubs die gründung der
super league vermeldet und europas
dachverband brüskiert so bald wie
möglich wollen sie spielen
dies sei dsl speed interface mit diesem
plan wird allen fußballfreunden und der
ganzen gesellschaft ins gesicht gespuckt
wir werden nicht zulassen dass man uns
den fußball die großbank jp morgan aus
new york soll das ganze finanzieren
startkapital dreieinhalb milliarden euro
den spielern in den clubs der
abtrünnigen drohen uefa und auch die
fifa mit weitreichenden konsequenzen
the players who play die spieler die in
dieser geschlossenen liga spielen
sollten werden ausgeschlossen von der
teilnahme bei der welt und der
europameisterschaft nicht nur fans wie
hier in liverpool lehnen die neue liga
ab auch regierungen stimmen ein
mir gefallen diese pläne nicht wir
werden beraten dazu kann ich nur sagen
dass das ich auch nicht alle details
weiß aber voll auch in der der aussage
des vereins oder auch von dortmund stehe
ich finde einfach dass ist wäre nicht
gut für den für den europäischen fußball
die champions league klubs aus münchen
dortmund und paris sind der super league
noch nicht beigetreten
aber auch dort ist klar wenn sie kommt
ist die champions league ein
auslaufmodell
die entscheidung ob münchen einer der
zwölf austragungsorte der fußball
europameisterschaft im sommer bleibt hat
das exekutivkomitee der uefa auf freitag
verschoben
damit wird der bayerischen
landeshauptstadt eine fristverlängerung
zur konzept
nachbesserung eingeräumt münchen will
bisher corona bedingt keine verbindliche
zuschauer garantie abgeben
die von der uefa gefordert weitere
wackelkandidaten bilbao und dublin ja
das ist eine ernste hängepartie danke
christian so wir haben zum schluss noch
ein wiedersehen für sie am anderen ende
der welt am flughafen auckland
neuseeland fallen sich menschen in die
arme die sich seit langer zeit nicht
gesehen haben nach mehr als einem jahr
der pandemie erlauben australien und
neuseeland jetzt wieder quarantäne
freies reisen zwischen beiden ländern
diese frau nimmt zum aller ersten mal
ihr enkelkind in den armen so was
wünschen wir uns so schnell wie möglich
auch für uns hier das wetter
vorübergehend milder wird es allerdings
sind schauer und gewitter inklusive mehr
dazu gleich von ostend elli im heute
journal um 21.45 hat der kollege claus
kleber fragen an die kanzlerkandidatin
der grüne jetzt gleich matthias fornoff
im zdf spezial
wir sehen uns morgen wieder wenn sie
mögen punkt 7 bis dann alles gute und in
allen einen angenehmen abend
[Musik]